hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar the impact of bed kiastra total
lab automation at houston methodist
hospital expanding microbiology lab
capacity and reducing turnaround times
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by bd
to learn more visit bd.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
dr scott wesley long dr long received
his
md degree in 2007 from the university of
texas medical branch utmb in galveston
texas where he also earned a phd in
experimental pathology
after finishing his doctoral studies dr
long completed a clinical pathology
residency at houston methodist
doctor long joined houston methodist
hospital in 2011 and received his
faculty appointment at the weil cornell
medical college in 2012.
he is sub-specialty boarded in both
medical microbiology from the abm and
clinical informatics from the american
board of pathology
he is currently an associate professor
of pathology and genomic medicine and
medical director of microbiology at
houston methodist hospital
we are also joined by miss
patricia churnock
ms chernoch received her bachelor of
science in microbiology from texas a m
university
since joining houston methodist hospital
in 1981 ms turnock has taken on
increasing responsibilities including
multiple teaching and supervisor
positions
she is the current microbiology lab
manager at houston methodist
dr long and ms turnock you may now begin
your presentation
all right thank you very much and thanks
everybody for joining us today um
look forward to talking to you about our
experience with the kystra and
what some of the benefits have been
for us here in the laboratory in houston
methodist
so just first in terms of disclosures i
don't have any relevant conflicts of
interest to disclose
at this point
um
and i think for most people who are
interested in you know lab automation
systems like the bd keystroke one of the
first
questions you are confronted with is
making a business case for each
administration
because uh
these systems are not obviously uh
inexpensive they are large capital
acquisitions
and
uh
you know as such require leadership
support
and buy-in and significant capital
resources to acquire
uh and hospitals have limited resources
i think we all can appreciate that
um in the modern age and that you know
to make the business case you're gonna
have to
uh generally generate some sort of
justification or roi
for your leadership to
justify the allocation of the capital
resources you need to acquire an
automation system
and so i think the question that
confronts
any of us certainly confronted us here
he's the methodist
back
years ago and we've started this process
and will confront anyone who goes to
acquire when these systems is how can
you justify
the acquisition of a large automation
line
or upgrading an automation line if you
have one already that you've outgrown
and so
uh one of the common ways that people
will
uh suggest that you try to
justify acquisitions like an automation
lag will be uh in terms of ftes and the
theoretical reduction in ftes
uh and that's usually what maybe your
bench technologists are worried about is
are people gonna get laid off
um
that sort of question and so we sort of
confronted that head on uh in the very
beginning
by essentially refusing to accept the
idea that we were going to reduce ftes
by acquiring an automation system it may
seem a little counterintuitive at first
but uh
what we realized in the reality of our
lab and our labor market was that uh
essentially we were almost always in a
constant state of hiring as the lab
expanded and to the point now
uh where we're somewhere in the root of
60 to 70 ftes
and it's just sort of we continue to add
beds we continue to add locations our
volumes continue to increase and so
we have enough
employees that almost at any point we're
fully staffed within a week or so
someone for one reason or other is
leaving because they're moving or
spouses job is moved or
other reasons so we're sort of
constantly hiring
and rather than focusing on a uh
reduction in ftes we
put forth to our leadership that we were
going to be able to use our
existing ftes more efficiently and bring
on more new testing and sort of absorb
more of this
constant year-over-year increase in
volume without additional ftes by
acquiring the system so it's a little
bit it's a little bit of a different
approach to trying to do
uh the justification and it also um
requires a little bit of finesse because
sometimes cost avoidance rois are harder
to get buy-in on
than you know a more direct uh sort of a
cost reduction roi like eliminating
positions or things of that nature
um
but we thought you know based upon the
labor market and for technologists i
think this is pretty much universal
across the nation
that we need to be able to maximize the
staffing that we did have
by acquiring this automation system to
cope with sort of our growing and
continuously growing volumes
um we also
argued that the automation lab would
benefit patient care
and so um
we were had a strong belief and
hypothesis that
automation would decrease turnaround
times and lead to patient care benefits
we know from prior work and study that
we did with multi-top when we first
brought that online
now probably about a decade ago
that if using maldi-tof for rapid
identification and setting up rapid
susceptibilities direct from blood
cultures that we could uh
basically reduce run around time
significantly and show a benefit for uh
length of stay and uh
morbidity mortality in our patients and
so
um we felt like that a variety of things
with the keystroke would also generate
similar benefits one would be a decrease
in re-streaking it's been published by
others not by us that using these
automation systems like the kystra you
get better colony isolation on the
plates you get more consistent streaking
pattern
you have a lower incidence of
re-streaking and that certainly has been
the case we've observed in our our pre
and post-go-live data um and then we
also thought that we would having
automation automated system might help
us reduce errors increase patient safety
um
and there is
another benefit i'll get to here in a
few slides uh it comes from the
continuous incubation and the fact that
in the automation system the plates are
living in incubator being imaged in the
incubator they're not getting taken out
and put at room temperature
for hours on end while they're being
read which actually leaves cultures to
turn positive faster
this is just
our track record and this helped with
our bond with leadership in terms of
what we did with maldi and how quickly
how we showed that with maldi that
faster turnaround times could benefit
patients
and so
[Music]
the fact we had done this previously and
shown that the decrease in turnaround
time could benefit patient care directly
uh actually helped justify the roi the
maldives very quickly helped us get a
second maldi and gave us some uh
political capital leadership that these
ideas in practice we could put them into
practice and and show the benefits that
we were suggesting
and this is just a figure from that
paper uh looking at the time to
identification and so you can see on the
this was from maldi um on the top line
you know in our old system for blood
cultures uh going from the culture
training positive to then
you know growing the positive up on a
plate and doing
um
identification susceptibility and
adjusting therapy
uh could take anywhere from 75 to full
fat anywhere from um
around 35 hours plus or minus some extra
time there
and then um
after we introduced the maldi and we
started doing uh essentially spinning
down the pellets from a positive blood
culture placing it directly in the maldi
and inoculating susceptibility from that
and validated that that we could reduce
essentially reduce turnaround time by
close to 48 hours
in terms of from having the culture
drawn to when the patient's
antimicrobial therapy could be adjusted
there's a very important stewardship
piece to that as well
but
that was sort of the background we used
to justify the benefits from
automation
uh and so this this reiterates um
reiterates these points essentially uh
the last point which was really the key
point i just kind of slipped in there
but um faster turnaround time is good
but it has to be acted upon right so if
you're turning around results faster but
they're sitting in the emr for
12 hours until the next you know day
when someone rounds on the patient
that
lacks impact at the bedside compared to
having an active
response to the results you're
generating and so the way we did that
with maldi was to
have active uh immigration stewardship
and certainly having an automation line
like the keystroke feeds into such a
process of if you're reducing your
turnaround time from continuous
incubation and things of that nature uh
you still need to have that robust uh
piece on the back end that your results
are getting to the patient's bedside and
getting acted on whether that's
antimicrobial stewardship pharmacist or
uh you know some sort of system of
alerts or other other mechanisms for
tackling it you do have to have action
to get the benefit
um
and so that's just it's just important
to remember that
you know be careful if you're promising
decreased turnaround time you don't have
those mechanisms you know you may have
difficulty realizing the bedside impact
at least in a consistent fashion
and so i think you know one thing is
microbiologist who knows that
traditional microbiology workflow takes
time
and
from accessioning to plating and then
incubation
uh you know traditional micro
pre-automation you know we get samples
in we plate them they go into an
incubator and then they sit in that
incubator for some amount of time
and
uh
at some point they're taken out to be
red but the reality is while they're in
the incubator
uh what's happening well more samples
are coming in
and the incubator door is getting opened
and closed
and then at the point where the racks
are taken out to be red some of those
plates have been in the incubator
you know possibly maybe 12 or 18 hours
depending on how you've done your
workflow uh some of them may have only
been in there you know shorter time
period so there's a lot of variation how
long things been incubating before they
get taken out to be read and sort of
traditional
environments
and then if they're positive you know if
they're negative at first read they go
back into the incubator and get right
again maybe a day later you know kind of
on a fixed interval
and you know this cycle sort of repeats
and
again incubator doors opening and
closing
um
and they're only read it six times
uh
and it's just sort of that's the
traditional workflow and
and it
worked uh for you know
decades but
um
automation offers a lot of benefits and
so
this is an obligatory
uh picture of the the keister system
this actually is
very similar in what our system here
methodist looks like now
we only we have five incubators instead
of six
but we do have the two inoculation
stations on the front end uh
and the two plate uh play garages so if
you're not familiar with the system just
orient you is how this differs from the
traditional workflow
you know there there's essentially
a range of processing options for
samples so you have fully automated
samples like maybe urines that are in
tubes
basically can be put in racks and loaded
into the uh inocula system
and then
the system will you know read the
barcode see it's a urine
pull
the plates out of the blue boxes there
on the far left
barcode those plates bring them over to
the inoculator
put your urine sample on the plate drop
a little bead onto the plate streak it
there in the in the hood and the inocula
and then take it on a bi-level track
back to the incubators in the back and
start imaging it on a set schedule
for some samples that are more complex
that technologists can inoculate them in
the hoods there at the inocula and more
of a semi-automated mode
or a sort of full manual inoculation
mode and then
what happens there at the computer
monitors along the line is you have your
text maybe on one way we do it one side
we have text who are reading and on the
other side we have techs who are doing
sort of the technical work up of those
specimens so
you have your readers that are sitting
there
looking at plate images so the plates
are imaged and the incubators on a
schedule
and then they mark colonies and things
for work up or mark the plates you're
negative and then your what we call
technical assistance on the other side
you know are the ones setting up the
maldives setting up the asts getting in
their queue uh colonies that have been
marked for work up and calling for those
plates from the incubator so until they
call for the pledge for work up the
plates are just sitting happy warm in
the incubator growing
so it's a much
better system for the pathogens on the
plate
in terms of getting good consistent
results and getting that shortening that
turnaround time
and it's just a continuous flow 24 7 for
us
um
that's just a picture just to give you
uh
orientation you've never seen the
streaking pattern with the bead uh with
the little magnetic bead on the plate
there in the top left
you can configure the streaking pattern
within
multiple there's a whole variety
of uh
pre-configured patterns you can do
custom patterns
um
and then that's just an image there at
the bottom of uh tech technologists
looking at plate images and working and
they're all the reading stations and the
work of dual monitors typically there's
a keystroke the keystore software is on
one and your lis is on the second
monitor and they can work there between
i've talked a lot about continuous
incubation um
so we actually wanted to test it before
we got the system in
i haven't had the time or the chance to
really publish this data anywhere but
i'll share it with you
i think others have published on it at
this point but i think before we went
live with the keystroke we didn't have a
full appreciation for the amount of
temperature deviation that a normal
auger plate went through
in a traditional clinical micro workflow
and i was determined to figure out what
that was and really quantify it so i
bought a usb temperature logger
off of amazon and placed the probe there
on the surface of the auger plate and
built this contraption
to place the stack of plates in with the
other plates in our workflow and
essentially take it to took it to uh our
technologists and accessioning to sit
here put this with your other plates
that you're uh
essentially and just you know let it go
through uh let it go through the
workflow and then i'll pull the data in
a few days and look at it
and so what we found
um
was that there could be up to like a
five hour long deviation in temperature
uh from a time that a plate was you know
picked up an accession put in the
incubator
there on the far left you can see it's
down at our room temperature is around
22 degrees c
and that it takes um these on the x-axis
these lines are about 12 hours apart so
it takes
several hours
um for the plates to actually get up to
you know towards that 38 degree mark
um and then what you see in the line is
there's sort of this continuous there's
a dip and then a slow recovery then a
big dip and a recovery
and so that's really a lot of what that
sawtooth thing you're seeing there is
the door being open and closed as more
samples are added or other plates are
taken out for reading and other things
causing minor perturbations in the
incubator temperature and then the big
dip that you see on the far right there
is when the plates were taken out for
reading and so
that's where you know
again some of those plates have been in
there now for
this my particular my tracker plate had
been in there for over 24 hours some of
the plates may have been in there
longer but sitting at room temperature
uh it drops very quickly really within
30 minutes the plate drops from the
incubator temperature down to room
temperature and then takes quite a while
to recover which is put back and so you
wind up with these big
temperature deviations
uh in the traditional workflow
um and then again this is just an uh
this this plate satin incubator is
longer but just showing the number of
sort of two degree perturbations in an
incubator traditional incubator over
several days
and um
sorry one problem
so that got us to thinking well
you know what does that actually do to
the terms of when plates turn positive
what's the actual impact of that
and so there was some published evidence
that
uh
with continuous incubation in the kystra
or automation system where that
continuous incubation that plates could
turn positive anywhere from 7 to 16
hours earlier
than traditional workflows and so we did
a pilot experiment
with
club numo and staph aureus to see if a
three-hour removal from the incubator
impaired the time to positive culture
detection
and
uh so again got a little creative put a
gopro and incubator over in a research
lab
and uh played it out
a couple of uh you know fixed
concentrations of organism onto some
blood auger plates put it in the
incubator with a gopro and a light
source
and set it up to incubate set up the
camera the gopro to take an image uh you
know every minute or so so we can get
really start to see a different time you
know when they started turning positive
and it doesn't project very well um
but essentially if you look at sort of
the
uh
on the left side where our continuous
plates and you can see some growth at
the six o'clock position of the upper
plate and a little bit of hemolysis on
the
12 o'clock position of the lower plate
which are the staff plates
um essentially the continuous incubation
we can start to see detectable growth
this particular concentration of
organism i used i could start to see
colonies that i could actually pick
um
by about eight hours whereas the ones
that i took out essentially in the
middle of the incubation set them out on
the bench top for three hours
back in
their colonies are just still not
detectable and in fact when we looked um
[Music]
they started being detectable about
three hours later so the amount of
deviation
to room temperature is really almost
exactly correlates to the how much
longer how much faster
your place will turn positive with
continuous incubation and that's led to
a lot of that's led us to actually
change some of our read times for
urine cultures and other other culture
types we can actually now read the
cultures earlier because of the
continuous incubation validated that and
then validated things like being able to
do the antimicrobial susceptibilities
at earlier time points so
um
it really the continuous incubation
really is one of the sort of killer
features of an automation line
um that will let you get positive
results faster and could really help
you know theoretically then help you get
results of bedside faster and get um
benefits to patients in that way
uh so this was the first sample type we
went live with was urines and so this
was our uh
looking at our time from plating to
identification
uh
for our urine cultures and the red line
is pre-keister and the blue line is post
keystroke and they're on the bottom
you've got hours
um
and so what you can tell is that you
know previously we were reading on a set
schedule pre-key stress so we had a
reading that was you know generally fell
around a day later and then a second
read
that would be you know basically day two
and then they would go out and with the
keystroke we instituted more of a 12
hour read
and then a read at 36 hours and so
um
by
in the text can always hold you know
they can always add an additional
incubation if they think you know
there's something growing but they can't
quite see the colonies yet they can
always add more uh which may be some of
what you see in that little third hump
from the on the post keystroke but uh
basically that's you know looking at
that looking at this graph you can see
that it shifted our our time to
identification of positive urine
um you know pretty pretty substantially
to the left i wish uh and i would show
that a different way here
in my next slide um and this is just our
percentile of urine cultures resulted
from platinum identification and so you
can see again the red is pre-key through
the blue as opposed keystrokes so
pre-kystra
um you know we were getting around half
of our
uh so it's interesting because the
halfway point is about the same but then
if you look at the actual individual
cultures the blue line has shifted over
to the left so you're getting uh earlier
identification and then um you're
hitting that uh
you know getting it's just you're
getting a lot of them identified sooner
is what i'm trying to say
and does it actually benefit patients um
that uh that is something we've looked
at it's kind of interesting um
so we looked at in the icu our ict
patients and we saw it for the first
three months or so after go live with
our patients with urine cultures we saw
a decreased length of stay but we were a
little skeptical that urine cultures and
icu patients could be that important and
so we kept watching and it was a
artifact it was something else going on
in the icu at that time
um we wanted to get in we went live with
urines first we've since within the
first year after go live we went live
with all of our specimen types we're
going to put on it put on the keystra
and um
you know i've since wanted to go back
and look at other specimen types
unfortunately there was this whole
global pandemic that happened and that's
just sort of
turned my schedule upside down and
certainly
altered the course of everything in our
icus and so we're sort of
have been waiting for the cove to calm
down enough that we have the time to
look at that data and then try to get
our icus back to more of a pre-covered
state so we have a decent comparison of
uh data in terms of patient cultures and
length of stay and morbidity mortality
those sorts of things it's just then
everything got a little bit perturbed
right around the time we started to look
at that data
so just to summarize the turnaround time
benefits again your cultures are going
to turn positive faster
it's it's you know it's really the
continuous incubation is is really cool
the ability to image the plates inside
the incubator
uh is very nice and the fact that they
can sit there in incubator until someone
calls for that plate to work it up is
just really fantastic
the streaking is much more consistent
and you get better colony isolation and
so you get fewer fewer repeats and fewer
restraints
i do believe i do know from our maldi
example for instance that faster
turnaround times can benefit patient
care
um
again we just haven't been able to i
haven't been able to pull the data and
actually do the studies uh here yet
thanks to the pandemic but we are
working on it and i think there's been
some other people who have published in
the meantime as well
so we're still working on our data so we
can share
that of course with the community
and
i will
again for your business case just to
summarize don't promise to reduce i
would recommend not promising a
reduction in fdes because unless you
really really think that'll happen
unless somehow by some miracle you're
overstaffed um work on promising the
increased efficiency and cost avoidance
even though it's a little bit of a
tougher road um patient care benefits
are real but they can be difficult to
quantify so if you're going to promise
that be ready to pull the data and make
that case after go live
um
you know there's an inherent skepticism
in most hospital leadership around
vendor provided roi so be prepared to
run your own numbers and have your own
estimate
because if you come in with a slick roi
from a vendor your leadership may not
buy into it and then um
the other thing and pat me get into this
too is this general you know caveats
about automation
a wise man dr wayne chandler once told
me uh
you know you can't automate your way out
of a bad process so the keystore is
going to change um
how your workflow in your lab works
uh you may have
and we learned we learned that sort of
early on in our preparation process we
sort of we thought we had questions when
we realized we were asking the wrong
questions
because it was going to change how we
did things
but that was okay and so you can't if
you're having issues with your workflow
in your lab or you're having
you can't just automate
you can't automate your way out of a bad
process you have to kind of fix the
process or realize how you know using a
new tool like the keystroke your
workflow and things are going to change
and you can
fix the process through the change
but it is a big change and so you have
to be the change management is really
critical and i think uh pat is going to
talk to us a lot more about that and we
don't have to answer any questions about
it i think i've exhausted my time i'll
throw up one quick acknowledgement slide
to all the team here at houston
methodist including our fantastic
technologist in the diagnostic micro lab
and i will now
hand it over to pat
thank you very much uh wes i will uh
elaborate on
the experience that we had in actually
educating our staff about the maldi
and
how we progressed on to the
implementation
basically you need to educate your
employees as soon as possible
because one of the things that you want
to do is get them prepared in their
mindset uh for what the changes are
going to be
we started asking for the keystra about
two years before it was approved and at
that time we started letting the
employees know what we were asking for
and basically
what it would do for the laboratory
we asked bd to come in and make a
presentation to all of our shifts so
they had some concept of what the
instrumentation looked like how it
operated and what they were in for
we actually started talking with the
employees about
we we didn't know what was going to
happen with schedule changes but we
tried to emphasize to them that we were
as dr long said
stating to the
upper management that we did not intend
to have a reduction of employees but
that we would
re use the employees in other areas
but i think you have to be up front with
the employees and tell them that we
don't know if we're going to have
employees coming in earlier staying
later or because the
instrument in itself can dictate those
uh
time readings of the cultures
so
you need to pick a site visit
this was probably the biggest eye opener
for us during this whole
event
look at a facility that is approximate
to your size
in volume
and we went to uh north shore in
illinois and we had pl we had worked
hours on creating a list of questions
that we weren't wanted to ask them we
took our camera with us we were as
prepared as what we could be
when we got there we took different
levels of employees along with us we
took dr long and myself some of our
chief techs a line employee but we
wanted to literally um
have everybody talk to compadre so that
we could get an idea as to how it was
going to affect those different areas of
where the employees work
as soon as we got there we realized that
our questions were irrelevant because we
were trying to fit a
uh
a square peg into a round hole
because what questions you're asking
don't necessarily fit into the workflow
that the keister is going to create
well some of the things that you can do
beforehand
you need to try to do for instance
if uh the rotational schedule one of the
things that we found to be
um
the employees always liked following
themselves and if they were reading
cultures today they read at the same
bench the next day and the next day for
that week so that they could have a
little continuity of it
well when we did our site visit and
watching the workflow we realized that
basically
that wasn't going to be happening
you can do it that way but we were
wanted to realize the most efficiencies
so we actually were going to be having
readers
and
bd calls them workers but we didn't want
people to feel like that they weren't
working if they were a reader so we
renamed them as task analysts or tas
so you were going to have people just
reading the cultures and marking for
uh activities to be done or tasked to be
done and then those tas would be pulling
off those uh tasks to be performed and
doing that that was a big change so we
actually started changing the rotational
schedule so that you were not reading
behind yourself
preparing the employees that when you
were sitting down to reading a culture
that you were looking at it with fresh
eyes every day
that helped them get used to you're
going to have to look at the work card
and not remember what you did to
something yesterday
we also changed some media and tubes
before we went live on the kystra we
changed to the e-swab before we went
live on the keystra that enabled the
employees to get used to collecting both
aerobic and anaerobic in the same
container
and basically getting used to handling
it and getting the nursing staff
used to collecting those types of
specimens
you're going to do a lot of work with
i.t you're going to be seeing them a
whole lot more than you ever did so make
sure you're on good terms with them
uh we uh on the changes uh you're going
to be using folders for the types of
cultures
and if you're in a laboratory that you
read cultures by source like you have a
urine bench or you have a sterile body
fluid bench or stool bench that's not
going to be much different than it is
but if you read cultures by patient name
which is what we did it's going to be a
big difference
we always read by culture name to keep
the patient work
consistent so if you had one organism
growing in multiple cultures on that
same patient
you had the opportunity to
keep them together
so this was a big change for us
but um
you're you're going to have to address
that with the staff also
you do not want to
go um and change everything at one time
this is a big change for the employees
and one of the things that we did is we
started with what we thought would be
the simplest culture type which should
be yearns every one of our technical
staff in our laboratory on whatever on
all three shifts basically knew how to
read urine cultures so one that would
involve every person on every shift to
start off with so we weren't you know
just letting the day shift do it like
many times things happen
it is very high volume and it's um we
get tons of them
we established our validation plan how
many things that how many cultures we
thought uh would not just show the work
would
be the same as cultures read by hand or
better than the cultures read by hand
but you had to prove it to the employees
and you would have to do some to let
them practice with
we took us
images at multiple times at eight hours
at 10 hours at 12 hours at 14 hours to
basically see which images were going to
give us the best isolated colonies we
involve the employees in this because
they're the ones who are going to have
to
look at the images to do the workups
don't reinvent the wheel if another
facility maybe the site visit that you
went to
told you that eight hours is not enough
uh we were that they've repeatedly
looked at it
take their word for it go on to another
like the 10 hour or the 12 hour
we developed reference pictures for the
employees and laminated them and put
them next to the workstation so the
employees had something to to look at so
they could say oh yes that this is the
colony uh
uh type or the colony count
um we we went from a poor plate method
for urines to
essentially the
calibrated loop method and so it was a
change for us and so that's one of the
reasons why we did the pictures
you want to make sure and train your
main years users first
uh because you're going to be doing
urines and so many of them you want to
train your medical laboratory assistance
first and the people who are going to
be the trainers
i think a lot of laboratories always
utilize the same employees to train and
train new new employees and
that helped us tremendously by starting
off with those
people
but you have to let the employees
practice and practice and practice i
can't emphasize enough that the
employees have to gain
confidence in this system before that
they will make sure that it works
and by them gaining confidence they'll
be able to read
uh and mark with authority and then move
on to the other ones we actually gave uh
each employee 10 cultures that they had
to
work on in the same type of
work uh scenario that they would
they could look at as many
images as they possibly wanted we had
all of our validation cultures
on uh the system that they could look at
the images and
basically put the work in the work card
and we would examine their work cards
and make sure that everything was done
appropriately
train
pick some staff that you know are good
troubleshooters and
train them on the actual
uh troubleshooting on the instrument
we actually chose that every employee
has to sign on to the keystra with an id
so we know who's doing what and that has
been a tremendous help because we can
actually see that employees are not
troubleshooting or are troubleshooting
or when they're opening and closing
cultures that really helps us pinpoint
problems
everybody needs to be able to call bd
and work through a resolution with them
our staff over the years have gotten so
comfortable with calling bd from our
medical laboratory assistants to our
chief techs every one of them is
comfortable in calling bd at any hour of
the day
and getting help from them
they routinely we have a group email for
the whole staff when they get through
calling they send an email out to the
team saying we've called this is the
problem this is the case number you
should be expecting a call from wherever
and
it really does work well
your specimen issues you do have to work
with nursing education to establish
requirements for the urine collection
tubes
we i wish we would have worked a little
harder on that to
we did get
the new collection kits in so they were
always in the gray top tube but we
didn't mandate it and
um i wish we would have because it would
have helped us
not to transfer specimens into great top
tubes to put them on the system
um but you have to make a decision if
it's not going to come in a gray top
tube what are you going to do to it are
you going to do it semi-automated or
automated
but those are things that you have to
decide before you're going to start your
system
urine culture reading can be a big
change for you depending on what method
you're currently using
um it is a quantitative method as all
urine cultures are but the method is
very different at least for us it was
and uh even if you're using a calibrated
loop it's still different than a and
then a classic calibrated loop so you do
have to get people used to that change
have pictures so your staff can look at
them and again
i can't emphasize enough how you need to
have your staff practice
and practice
this is an example of an e coli and
colony count of 10 to the fourth
and um
this is directly taken from
the instrument in itself
couple of things about the culture
workup that you have to understand in
order to be able to troubleshoot
problems with culture interpretation
you're going to have many more hands on
one culture and it can be very confusing
so you have the person who does the
first read marks it for work up somebody
else is going to be doing the
identification somebody else may be
doing the susceptibility and then
somebody else is coming back and putting
results in or doing a second read
so
it is basically a lot of fingers in the
pie
you have to make sure everybody
documents
all of their work one of the biggest
problems we have faced is that you mark
stuff in the keystroke but you document
and you build out of our lis and that
has been confusing for staff and it's
one thing we really emphasize when we
are training
we the employees got together and
actually made sure that all of the
duties of the reader versus the task
analysts were defined and i can tell you
that
we've redefined them several times
because we have fine-tuned things
over the years but we
we get the employees together about
every six months review it
and
then
review those new duties with all of the
employees
everybody is held accountable for their
responsibilities
one of the things you may want to
re-examine is spot testing do you uh if
you are going to do spot testing is the
reader going to do it or is the task
analyst going to do it
we tried uh eliminating the spot testing
like indoles for
e coli and that but it kind of
overwhelmed the person with the maldives
and actually we found that it was
delaying
identifications so we re-implemented
the spot testing and we saw a decrease
in the turnaround time on the
identifications
sometimes it's trial and error
remember that every time you pull the
plates out of the incubator you are
cutting into the incubation time so you
really have to work with the staff on
practicing with the images put any kind
of organism you can think of on plates
put them in the incubator and let them
view what the colonies look like
and you do need to remember to let the
employees have a voice in defining the
workflow
they know it better than you do as a
manager or as a pathologist
and they will accept the changes much
better if you actually let them
participate in it
when you are getting ready to go live we
have to make sure that everyone gets a
chance to be the reader or the task
analyst or the inocula before the system
goes live with that type of culture we
made sure everybody could do the urines
on all areas
got that down well we probably
had urines going for about three to four
months before we started on the second
type of cultures which were sterile body
fluids
um
and that worked to our advantage because
everybody felt pretty comfortable with
it
because we made sure that everybody got
to be a reader and a task analyst
the employees
made
suggestions on workflow changes
constantly we had to kind of say we've
got to have a way to for everybody to
turn in suggestions for the workflow
changes for us to evaluate them and then
get back to the employees as to why it
worked or why it didn't work
again you have to work with your nursing
education about the collection
containers for each set of cultures that
you are ready to to bring on
it when you're going to bring the next
set of cultures on
is the employees that are are the
employees that are going to be doing it
are they learning a new skill
all of our employees um knew how all of
our
mlts and um mls's knew how to read urine
cultures
but the m uh the evening and night shift
did not know how to read sterile body
fluids or respiratories or anything else
so when we started on the next set of
cultures i.e sterile body fluids
we uh made sure that we started with
these sterile body fluids because they
would have some positive but not a
tremendous number of positives and it
would ease them in to be able to looking
at cultures with um
broths and examining the cultures on
multiple days
uh the positive blood cultures were
included in this and uh i was really
pleased with how this
went with the employees that had no
did not have skills in reading the other
cultures uh it was more of a gradual
approach to it and they did quite well
it took us about three to four months
again to get
all of them trained and uh on reading
the cultures and then
implementing the sterile body fluids
validate your cultures again with
specific reading times
um train the employees and let them
practice practice and practice i can't
emphasize enough how important letting
the employees have time on the
instrument um and
to so that they can train their eyes
make sure everyone gets uh practice on
again the reading the and the uh ta part
and again they we redefine the duties of
the tas every time we put on a new
culture type
those duties and that sometimes changed
oh once it's live again make sure that
uh before you're thinking about your
third set as we did
you could do
two uh go lives or four go live
but make sure everybody gets a chance to
be the reader and the ta and the inocula
tech before you go on to your next one
you think you thought of everything you
just knew it but then reality heads
and
usually you've thought of all the major
issues but it's the little things that
um you don't think about and those are
the ones that the employees will come up
with well
we didn't decide where this uh racks
were going to go in the incubator it's
confusing which shift is doing them so
it's those types of thing that we had to
address later
in the last go live we just repeated the
steps from previous ones we started off
with the respiratory cultures having
images taken at a longer time
essentially 24 hours and we have not
changed that that seems to work really
well for us on those respiratory
cultures we don't have to send out a a
report that says it's too young we're
going to you know read it later
we usually have something very visible
to grow with 24 hours
and you also have to consider those
cultures that are not going to go on the
keystroke are you going to inoculate
them on the keister in the semi
automated mode or are you going to
inoculate them manually for instance
like your anaerobic cultures if you have
any other plated cultures
iv catheter tips or something like that
some of the lessons that we learned were
essentially one of the most challenging
areas was the inocula specimens that had
afb and fungus cultures and aerobic and
anaerobic cultures we found we couldn't
split those specimens you actually had
to take the specimen like bronchial
washings and do everything in a manual
mode it got too confusing for the
employees
we did find that inoculation of cultures
that don't incubate on the keystroke
works extremely well they just go to a
bin we pick them up put them in the
anaerobe bins
great utilize it as much as you can
there are problems in keeping the work
on the lis the recording results on the
lis and the marking on the kystra make
sure that you outline what goes on each
the workflow documentation
you just have to keep on people
planning ahead is absolutely essential
and anything that you can do beforehand
making changes rotational reading
cultures
containers that all will help
one of the things that we did not
anticipate that the employees told us
about was that
it
the employees felt differently about
reading the cultures they felt that in
the old way when you were handling the
cultures themselves that they had a
feeling of accomplishment when they went
home they did a day's work they left
feeling good i got it all done
when they leave now
they don't have quite that same feeling
because they may have just read the
cultures and there's still some that are
have to be read because it's so
continuous and it's um a little bit
different in a mentality so that did
affect the employees in that way
making sure everybody knows how to
troubleshoot it that is a requirement
here you have to troubleshoot it
yourself
be sure and listen to the employees
they've come up with absolutely
fantastic ideas
and it is stressful so uh
we celebrated a lot when we had you know
when the urines went through and we were
uh at the end of that right before we
went to the
next culture type we did celebrate you
have to make sure that you do
and yes we would do it again
so that's my presentation thank you very
much for your attendance and um
i think that now that
we'll be entertaining questions
thank you dr long and ms chernock for
your informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for let's get started
our first question is
how has the kiastra system helped your
lab during covid
i wanted to i was just i saw this
question at first and i thought well i
mean really it didn't run covet tests so
it wasn't that helpful but actually one
of the things that i would say was
helpful was
uh it since it changed our workflow and
we went to a situation you know before
we had the kystra
uh there were certain shifts you know in
the middle of the night where plates
maybe weren't being read
uh and not all technologists uh
were reading plates there there was
cross training but there wasn't
the same sort of cross training is once
we move to the keystroke we move to
you know the automation system and
plates were being you know coming ready
to be read 24 7 we had to train more of
our text in reading plates and do other
things and so i think because of that at
least in my perception
during covid when we went through peaks
where we had multiple technologists who
were out unfortunately either with covet
or with family members code et cetera
um i think it made us a little bit more
flexible in terms of our labor and how
we could have other techs pick up the
slack
to do plate reading other things i think
i think in that case the sort of the way
it changed our workflow and our
crosstraining helped
right thank you
our next question is it possible to have
incubators at different atmospheres eg
ambient versus five percent co2
yes we do have uh two co2 incubators and
three ambient air
incubators on the
keestra
all right
next question
how did the incubation decrease impact
your staffing models assuming maldi tof
changed it in the first place and this
would have changed it again
we actually didn't change our
staffing models for the culture reading
we
we did try some employees coming in
earlier um for a while and some staying
later
but we found that um
it didn't help
it really actually hurt
more so than it helped we kept our
regular three shifts
um when we actually
were able to get some new positions
because of increased workload
we moved them to the shifts that had the
heaviest reader time
and
that helped us even it out a little
all right
next question
how do you deal with clsi's organism age
requirements for susceptibility testing
we did a validation on identification on
how old the colonies were if they were
um
a lot of times your colonies are about
12 hours old when you
pick them
and we did susceptibility testing at
that time that we picked them
which is usually even though it's 12
hours when you read them by the time you
pick them it may be
12 hours
and then at the
routine time of about 24 hours and we
did not see
any significant difference
for instance there was no
interpretation difference in the
susceptibilities
thank you
next question
have you considered having text work
from home when reading plates from the
computer
i marked this one i i wanted to say uh
it's certainly something i have i have
thought about
um
you know there's certain uh
cap requirements and and regulations uh
related to digital pathology and there's
been certain relaxations
um
you know i think to do it properly you
would probably have to issue
technologists a standard uh you know the
monitor on the keystroke is a fairly
high definition monitor i think you
would have to replicate that
at home uh to have some consistency but
it is
we live in houston we have you know
hurricanes and freezes and other things
where it makes it difficult for people
to come into work um and it you know it
is
it is in some ways
attractive to me uh as a medical
director to think about possibilities of
you know is there a way we could have
people
uh read place from home and i think i
think that future may be coming
but i do think there's just some
logistics to be worked out in terms of
you know standardization monitors and um
and how to operationalize it um
in terms of you know uh
paying for the employees and and how
that you know would they how would you
pay the employees that are off-site and
how would you you know track the work
but i do think it is i do think it's a
tantalizing possibility with the system
that may be on the horizon i don't know
how far it is out there
i did can tell you that um i have the
system on my
um
computer in the office and they'll mark
it uh for a manager review and it's so
nice to be able to just to view it here
and not have to go into the laboratory
and i can make comments on it and it
works out great
in that respect
okay great thank you
next question
did you look at the copan wasp lab2 what
were the reasons benefits that led you
to go with the bd kystra
uh i would say just off the top my
recollection is when we looked at it in
our initial uh
for our volumes and our throughput um
once they did the final we we did
discuss with both vendors and that the
copan the wasp system came back and we
were going to need two separate wasp
lines
and by the time
we were going to have enough i guess the
equivalent wasp system was really going
to be not
that much uh less expensive than the
keystra and
for that reason
um that was one of the major drivers for
me and then also we're just we're also
you know full disclosure a fairly beady
heavy operation with
instrumentation and so um we had that
pre-existing vendor relationship
uh and so that made the decision a
little easier too but um
you know i think that for me and i was
associate director at the time but that
was one of the major
things was once we finally did the final
calculations it wasn't actually all that
much before it wasn't all that much more
cheaper than the keister system that met
our needs
right thank you
next question
can you share a little information about
the demographics in your lab employees
um yes um our employees uh here in the
laboratory
it's probably
um
less than 60 we probably have about 80
percent of our employees that are less
than 60
uh and the remaining um 20
or over 60.
the majority of the older employees
adapted very well to it
the new employees the new graduates oh
my gosh they just take to it like a fish
to water
um the
other employees
in the mid-range
do very well with it
they may take a little bit longer
because they're not as quite as used to
all the
features of the computer
but overall it was very well received
we are the only ones in uh houston who
has who have the size uh keister that we
do
and i can tell you that it's been a
feature that has helped us with our
staffing we have people come to work
here because of the kystra because we
have an automation line and we have a
lot of other toys and um people
especially the younger techs migrate to
a place that has automation
and a technology
okay
next question what kind of communication
did you provide your clinicians as far
as changes in the go lives
we didn't
i mean i think we um so there were
uh you know we did a lot of pre-work in
terms of switching specimen containers
to the swap contain standardizing
specimen containers before long before
we went live with the system we tried to
preload as many changes as we could
um to sort of get those you know get the
swabs changed out and get any old swabs
out of sort of the supply chain
uh
off the floors before i went live and
then i think in terms of
um
yeah but since it didn't change anything
in terms of how they were ordering
cultures or uh
you know things on their end you know we
didn't do any specific
uh communications about uh the go wires
on the keystroke because for the
clinicians it was fairly seamless
we certainly once we were live you know
promoted it in our departmental
newsletter and things and
and things of that nature but it didn't
we generally only notify clinicians that
there's uh
you know if we're changing a test um
or they need to change something about
how they're practicing or order
something differently or you know new
tests we bring online those sorts of
things
um but i don't remember any specific
notifications about our keester go lives
because it was uh
for
the most part it was fairly seamless for
our clinicians
all right
next question have you been able to
reduce the workload for employees even
without looking to reduce total fte
counts
i don't think our employee workload has
gone down because our overall workload
is pretty much increased
um
continue how would you think
our workload in has increased
so dramatically
in 21
that i have gotten six new positions
so i i don't think that that question is
relevant for us
all right we just have too much organic
growth in the system uh to really gauge
that
okay well it looks like we have time for
one more question
how many times did you present your
justification to leadership to attain
it um i would say to me it felt like
several times we kind of we started
initial discussions
uh
there was money allocated for sort of us
some architectural studies and analysis
and and
feasibility studies and and looking at
you know as part of a larger move our
lab from one building to another
uh with automation in mind and then
there was
um we sort of went forward at one point
and then stopped for some more financial
reviews coming out of leadership and
provided more justification and then
after that period
uh it finally got approved and
after code everything pre-code was a
little fuzzy but there was sort of a
couple of years of starts and stops and
multiple justifications we went through
before we finally got the
full ticket price approved
it was on the third year like dr long
says and for such a huge expenditure for
us
that's about how long it usually takes
us
well thank you again dr long and ms
churnock for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor bd for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye